we are leading the way and the greatest  human advancement of all time he's  unlike anything we've seen before and  he's entirely in our control and  initiate sequence what happened  you've got yourself killed  you have been given a second chance I've  developed an army of soldiers like  yourself improve enhance welcome to the  circus  the technology in your veins will make  you faster stronger  and heal you instantly  it doesn't go right I've been  manipulating you set the next target for  elimination  you are my weapon  he made me but you can't control me for  [Music]  come for you  [Music]  looking forward to it  you can't get ink a little Joss  oh man oh [ __ ]  you  you